c'est suédois bas ouais comme les Chris
Prolls ouais ouais et comme le saumon a
du saumon suédois ouais sans doute un
peu oui parce qu'il y a la mer donc mais
le gros c'est quand même la Norvège
c'est vrai mais pourquoi alors pourquoi
les Norvégiens sont hyper forts en
saumon parce que ce sont les premiers
qui ont senti le potentiel qu'il y avait
à élever du saumon si bien
sûr ils ont
fait des fermes dans les fiordes ce qui
pose d'ailleurs un problème écologique
parce qu'il y a une concentration de
saumon très élevé mais c'est les
premiers qui ont senti se marcher les
deuxièmes c'est les Chiliens non le
Chili c'est la Norvège de
l'hémisphère Chili tout à fait et
l'écossé est pas mal aussi ah l'écossé
oui mais en plus petite quantité donc il
est un peu plus cher on a de la truite
qui vient d'arriver c'est magnifique je
vais demander je vais bander les yeux de
quelqu'un alors déjà moi comme ça
visuellement les deux ne me chauffent
pas du tout les deux me chauffent pas du
tout on va demander au plus sale d'entre
nous
Gill de goûter bien entendu un peu de
CR ils vont préparer ça préparer ça
alors on va on va mélanger après on va
mélanger et tu vas devoir dire truite ou
saumon d'accord truite saumon truite
saumon truc saumon Olivier je vais te
demander d'aller un petit peu là-bas
merci merci alors tu veux je veux que tu
fermes les yeux oui ça y est àorte àorte
ferme les yeux un couteau ça permettrait
de à plusieurs j'ai déjà trouvé où est
le saumon et où est la truite non mais
moi aussi je sais déjà où est le saumon
ù est la truite ouais
ça a t'inquiète
t'inquiète on peut dire bravo aux
équipes qui ont trouvé de la truite et
saon alors je vais vous dire j'ai
toujours de la truite il y a un magasin
juste en face donc si pas la
TR on on va pas on va pas aussi
féliciter l'équipe de savoir traverser
la
rue est-ce qu'on peut avoir par contre
un truc pour lui bander les yeux s'il
vous plaît ah vous l'avez pas on lui
bander les yeux et je vais qu'on amène
une moto il va
mot là je vais le faire dégueulasse
musique
musique il arrive il arrive arrête non
non il arrive bientôt VO
voilà pas très pratique elle est un peu
petite cette serviette k k mec il a pas
il y a pas plus grand comme
serviette en diagonal il t'ne une
serviécras le
nez ça peut que te faire du bien met sur
la tête directement qu'est-ce que
tu on pas un saut un
saut rien là c'est bon
voilà amenez une moto s'il vous plaît
c'est bon voilà c'est flatteur en tout
cas mélange it's no good alors chez vous
on va rappeler Olivier il est 20h25
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure donc truite
saumon truite saumon saumon truite la
truite déjà elle est française puis que
je sais la truite est majoritairement
française elle vient des Landes ou des
Pyrénées alors il y a aussi les Pyrénées
espagnoles mais ça restera toujours plus
près que de faire venir du saumon de
Norvège sachant qu'en plus certains
saumons que vous achetez ils ont été
élevés en Norvège ils ont été fumés et
tranchés en Pologne et ils sont vendus
en France parce que les Polonais ont
beaucoup d'industrie agroalimentaire sur
les poissons fumés ce qu' dit parle de
toi ça t'intéresse oui donc pour
l'empreinte carbone c'est im c'est pour
ça qu'encore une fois pour le prix
carbone après pour le prestige mais vous
pouvez très bien mettre de la truite à
vos invités et pas leur dire que c'est
de la truite exactement alors je vais
faire goûter Gill Verz attention truite
saumon saumon truite saumon truite Tru
saumon sur mon truc je vais demander
d'abord je vais demander attends s lui
dire c'est quoi le
bailand
al oui ça c'est là ouais et voyez le but
c'est qu'il voit pas de différence parce
qu'en fait c'est là où ça voudra dire
que ça a un
intérêt on sa c'est quoi voilà ah merde
ah ouais quand même ah ouais d'accord
allez tu vois comme quoi comme quoi
alors comme quoi alors s'il vous plaît
est-ce qu'on peut montrer au public s'il
vous plaît la caméraah viens là viens là
viens à côté de moi mon amène la
pancarte et tu la mets au au est sûr
qu'il voit rien oui rien du tout vous
pouvez être serein che vous regardez
voilà Tromp donc attention ou là là là
là déjà visuellement c'est compliqué
alors vousêtes surpris C avoué je je
suis surpris c'est vrai que je suis
surpris j'avoue attention c'est vous qui
me donnez la bqué i c'est moi musique de
suspense sachez chez vous que ce qui est
réalisé ce soir ça n'a jamais ça n'a
jamais été fait en télévision en direct
je vais demander à toutes les personnes
qui nous regardent d'éloigner les
enfants
une télé bulgare qui l' fait il y a 50
ans mais ça s mal passé tu pas fermer ta
gueule un peu ton nez va
bienre ça va arver ouvre bien la bouche
je vais te
mettre je vais te mettre
quoi saum la truite pris où ça déjà à
droite
la
boucheou mais sans déconner me c'est
meouvre la bouche comme
çais V
mezil attention arê ça
pu attends dis
rien pourir un peuau pour' vous plat on
a des
invités s'il vous plaît là
oh de JAV c'est de la
dinde c'est de la dind quand vous voulez
je vous donne mon verdict attends
attsatts je vais donner le deè je don de
Don donner
deè ah c'est les pades deè est-ce que tu
as aimé ça déjà j'ai adoré c'est vrai ah
j'en voudrais plus ah ouais tu pour
finir pourquoi tu
ris pas manger mais il est là devant toi
le truc là
voilà attention atttion
atttion mais
non mais qu' est con c'est pas possible
doucement doucement
voilà sachez que cette expérience a été
réalisée deux fois dans le monde
centrecage n pasardos une fois en
Bulgarie mais ça s'est très très mal
passé donc là on espère que jacardos
évite les vannes s'il te
plaît alors alors premère ou deè
première le premier que je va fais
goûter si mes souvenirs sont exacts
c'était celui-ci je vais te demander de
me ramener la pancarte petit Patrick
merci
Patrick donc
assiette rouge le premier que je t'ai
fait goûter pour toi c'était de la
truite ou du saumon déjà qu'est-ce que
tu as préféré le 1 ou le 2 le 1 le 1
ouais tu as préféré le 1 oui le 1 pour
toi c'était quoi la truitere j'adore la
truite la truitere j'adore la truite
c'est de la truite ou de la truitere
truite j'adore la truite et donc en deux
tu as moins aimé le blanc puisque pour
toi c'était du saumon du saumon j'ai
moins aimé le saumon il avait un petit
gût de fumé mais derrière fumée est-ce
que tu trouvais pas que le saon avait un
petit gût de
truite je reste sur mes positions c'est
c'est très proche mais donchabitude donc
donc pour toi pour toi pour lui pour lui
l'assiette rouge c'est de la truite et
l'assiette blanche c'est du saumon Gill
je vais te demander d'enlever ton
accoutrement maintenant vas-y merci oui
maintenant Gill regarde en un je t'ai
fait goûter ça oui c'est donc du saumon
rouge oui et après tu as mangé de la
truite oui et donc en fait tu t'es
trompé
[Applaudissements]
totalement merci Olivier c'est très
intéressant parce que ça veut dire que
c'est très proche et c'est ça ce qu'il
faut comprendre oui c'est la même chose
bonne bonne démonstration casse pas tout
bord
oh ouais en tout cas tu es magnifique
comme ça régalé merci euh